i moved to this great state six months
ago okay and i gotta tell you as i
opened with you guys have done it right
and it's it's you and it's you and it's
you and it's you and it's everyone in
this room and it's that florida man knew
something that the rest of us had
forgotten or maybe we never knew and i
promise you that i am here to keep
florida florida and i'm also here to
support this guy ladies and gentlemen
governor ron desantis everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
all right people it is june 6th 2022 i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report we
are live streaming on rumble on youtube
and on blaze tv and yes that was a
couple days ago june 2nd to be exactly
in orlando
uh in orlando florida the home of disney
that was the last show for the don't
burn this country tour
and that guy was nice enough to join me
on stage florida governor ron desantis
and uh basically brought down the house
sold out thousand people it was just an
awesome show it was an incredible way uh
to end a wildly successful tour and
i'm finally home for a little bit and
very excited uh to be to be back here
and back in studio with you guys and
back live and all that good stuff so we
can sort of focus in and get back to
doing what we do best but it was really
just great so i want to uh talk a little
bit about the show with ron desantis
some of the protesters because we had
the tolerant and diverse leftist loony
people outside and inside repeatedly
interrupting the event uh because you
know they're they're so tolerant and
decent and they're open and honest and
they just you know
all that good stuff uh so we're gonna
talk about that then we're going to talk
about some of the things that ron
desantis is doing right here in florida
uh and then we're going to talk about
some of the things that joe biden is
doing wrong all across america and by
the way the full interview
that i did with governor desantis about
45 minutes uh will be up across all
platforms i think we're putting some of
that up is that later today or is that
yeah some of that's going up later today
and then by the way we just decided that
the 45 minutes that i did beforehand my
solo talk is part stand up it's part
messing with the crowd it's part lecture
it's it's a lot of parts uh we are going
to put that up as a special on locals
exclusively should be up in the next
couple weeks we'll have more on that oh
and by the way
i wasn't going to announce this until
tomorrow but i'm feeling good about
things on july 14th even though we're
ending the tour the tour is over we had
a great book tour it was really really
great but uh the one thing that we did
not do
was do a show in my new hometown of
miami so we have just added a miami stop
i think i'm going to do a live reuben
report like we'll write the entire show
that day it'll be different than
anything else that we've done we'll do
it with some video and clips and all
that good stuff at the miami improv on
july 14th we just added that you can go
to davereuben.com
events all right let's get to the show
real quick though i want to talk to you
guys about relief band are joe biden and
the democrats disastrous policies making
you nauseous i know they're making me
nauseous did you know that one out of
three americans regularly suffer from
nausea but there's a solution you've got
to check out relief band relief bands
the fda's number one cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and much more how it works
is relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of the
brain that controls nausea then it
blocks the signal your brain is sending
to your stomach telling you that you're
sick it's like the name says it's
legitimately a band that you wear on
your wrist to give you relief from
nausea and anxiety and you change the
intensity depending on how you're
feeling it's that simple the technology
was originally developed over 20 years
ago in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients but now through a relief band
it's available to the masses plus it's
100 drug-free non-drowsy and provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
and they're just they've just released
their newest model relief band sport the
sport is waterproof has extended battery
life and can even attach to your apple
or android watch so if you're finally
taking that summer trip or just nauseous
from everything going on in the world
i've got good news right now you can
join over the 100 000 relief band users
with this exclusive offer just for
reuben report listeners go to
reliefband.com use promo code ruben
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30 day money
back guarantee r e l i e f b a m d dot
com
use promo code ruben for 20 off plus
free shipping all right so let's talk a
little bit about what happened in
orlando uh first i think we've got some
video of um
no we're gonna do something else okay
let's do something else we've got some
images we're gonna start with here's a
couple images of the event it was really
just uh fantastic so yeah about a
thousand people at the plaza live right
there in disney country and let me tell
you that during the uh the vip meet and
greet after the show uh well first let's
get to this next image let's go one more
image i think we got one more here do we
have the there's me in the gov and then
there's one more we got the
the brandon one we got the brand there
we go i gave the man a let's go brandon
t-shirt on stage he kept calling
i didn't know he was gonna do this i
know he calls joe biden brandon a lot
but he just kept saying it he actually
never said biden or joe or joe biden
where the president he just kept saying
branded so i you i give out t-shirts
during the show and i gave him that's an
official reuben report let's go brandon
uh t-shirt which you can get at dave
daverubin.store
by the way uh but anyway um it was just
an absolutely great event and all we
talked about was freedom
and liberty and limited government and
all of that good stuff there was no
racism there was no bigotry uh
protesters did come into the event and
repeatedly interrupt the governor and
they plan it you know these people they
really are organized and i always say
you got to give the devil his due they
don't just show up and scream they time
it out so one will go up and scream and
then they get kicked out and then they
time it so five minutes later someone
else goes up and screams something else
they always have their phones they try
to make it seem like they're the victim
i'm not going to show any of the videos
that they posted or any of their tweets
several of them were actual people
either running for office in florida or
people that are local officials and they
feel that they can use their free speech
to infringe on someone else's free
speech
but uh let's let's jump ahead to this uh
locals community breakfast uh image so
the next morning uh this is about a
hundred people from the locals community
who showed up i paid for breakfast for
everybody and we got to meet real people
look at those smiling happy people and
that really has been uh the beauty of
the entire tour more than anything else
and the beauty of moving to florida uh
and seeing happy people again getting
out there and ignoring all the crazy
lunatics we're gonna show you some video
of the people outside i'll show you the
people outside i'm not going to show you
the people inside but i just want to
tell you one or two things sort of uh
sort of more on the dl side of of
meeting the governor i've met him a few
times but getting to spend a little more
time with him so we're backstage before
the event and he's just in the green
room solo actually and they asked me to
go in so i go and we're chatting for a
couple minutes and he's asking me about
the kids and about david and then david
came in and then a couple of my team
members came in and i introduced him to
everybody i said hey this is connor my
director this is michael my producer
this is phoenix my associate producer
and he goes phoenix
you're you're associate producer isn't
that the guy in the book
and yes there's a story in the book
about phoenix how he was my intern and i
offered him a job because i said you
don't need to go to college anymore let
me just give you a job and in the book
he actually goes back to college but
then the book got printed and then he
decided to drop out of college and come
work for us and move down to miami but
it was just so cool it was like the guy
obviously read the book i mentioned
somebody's name and he's like oh you're
the guy from the book so it's like this
guy's not faking it like he actually
cares about this stuff he's actually
doing his homework he's reading books
and all of
that good stuff and the event was just
uh it was just spectacular like it
really was just spectacular but the
proof is in the pudding and as i said
earlier uh we are going to show you the
full uh video a little bit later now
we've got some video that we're going to
show them right now
oh let's do some protesters we got some
protesters outside take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so there are a couple protesters
outside now again i said a bunch of them
bust in and they interrupt the talk and
they feel that they can use their speech
to infringe on your speech but these
fools in the middle of pride month they
are protesting
a guy who happens to be gay it's the
least interesting thing about me and
it's something that i wish i didn't have
to talk about i only have to talk about
it because of these ridiculous people
but we say gay we say gay as the
governor is on stage with a gay guy
in orlando home of disney after he sent
us two onesies for the upcoming babies
that we're gonna have and it's like
they're just ridiculous they are just
absolutely absolutely ridiculous let's
zoom on zoom in on one of the photos
because you know they take photos right
so they're very upset about homophobia
they were also very angry about governor
desantis and guns even though there's no
problems here in florida about that but
they take smiley pictures together and
then of course reuben sucks too
that's what they wrote there and i felt
that that was a very homophobic thing to
say that's how ridiculous absolutely
completely bananas ridiculous these
people are but it's not just the people
in florida i mean this is what i said on
stage it's like
imagine living in florida the freest
state in the union the place that stayed
open the place that's just
absolutely flourishing right now
thriving and the economy and just
everything is going so well here but you
know what if you want to find problems
you'll always find problems right like
if you just are always focused on there
is something to be angry about there is
something to be aggrieved about there is
something wrong with society well of
course you're always going to find it
there is nothing that is perfect but it
is so obvious that this is by and by by
a long stretch this is the best place to
live right now and these people who have
it so good
so good they want to take down the guy
that has been leading it but it's not
just here uh this is from uh the daily
news look at this we just saw this this
morning so this is was posted by a guy
by the name of senator brad hollyman who
is a state senator apparently in new
york as lgbtq elected officials we
demand that chelsea piers in new york
city cancel the event with don't say gay
florida governor ron desantis during
pride month 2022 in chelsea the heart of
our community and there's a picture of
chelsea pierce now let me tell you
something about chelsea piers okay
chelsea piers is this huge
awesome sports facility on the west side
on the hudson river in new york city
chelsea piers i don't want to brag
people connor daphne you're going to
find out something about me today
many years ago i played in the new york
city gay men's basketball league okay
and i was most improved player about
seven years right now more than seven
years ago about nine years ago his most
improved player i was already in my late
30s and and i was most improved player
okay so
these people are just completely
ridiculous uh as you guys know it's not
don't say gay just as easily could have
called it don't say straight you don't
want teachers talking about sexuality
and gender and gender identity and all
of this nonsense um and these people are
actually i would argue at this point
these leftist clowns these lgbt lmnop
people are doing more damage to gay
rights and equality and everything else
than than anyone really on the right is
at this point i would say because
they're jamming it in everyone's faces
and that's not a sex joke but that's
what they're doing well i guess it was a
sex joke that's what they're doing
people just want to live and let live
people want adults to be in whatever
relationship they want people want to
have religious liberty and you make
choices and other people make choices
that's the exchange that we've done
really well in the united states but
these people that protest the people who
are pushing
for freedom are absolutely ridiculous
but show up show his tweet one more time
he's very concerned this is happening in
new york city this is happening in new
york city during pride month i'm very
upset about this and it's happening in
chelsea piers and all the gays live in
chelsea and ron desantis obviously
doesn't like gays well here's an image
of ron desantis with me and my husband
yeah there you go look how much he hates
gays there he is sandwiched between two
gays
ugh it's just exhausting it's just
exhausting because it's an alternate
reality these there's a reality there is
reality and you guys live in reality and
by the way you know as i just said i we
did this locals made up this breakfast
and
people consistently say what is to me
the nicest thing you can possibly say to
me which is you help keep me sane and
then i always say to them will you help
keep me sane so we're even and these
other people they live in an alternate
reality they live in a reality where
that man
who was asking me and my husband about
our kids uh is the number one homophobe
and they are trying to protest him and
stop him from speaking it's it's
they
god i
i don't like you people
let's talk about real estate agents i
trust because i want to talk about
people i like you know that buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do it's
more stressful than even protesting ron
desantis and it can be 10 times worse if
you're not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment that's a lot of
responsibility and you need you need an
agent who takes that seriously that's
why i recommend real estate agents i
trust they work with only the best
agents in every market they do their
homework talking to every agent before
inviting them to join their network and
here's a big one they only work with
full-time pros no part-timer
inexperienced agents plus it's owned by
my buddy glenn beck their team makes the
intro and then follows you through the
buying or selling process to make sure
that you're satisfied the agents they
work with have long track records and
are the best sellers in their field
they're part of this audience they share
your values and they're almost anywhere
you want to go including orlando florida
the process is simple just go to
realestateagentsidetrust.com today and
provide them with some basic info their
team will contact you to make an
introduction to their preferred agent in
your town and now back to me you know an
interesting point so we do the the meet
and greet after and not you know people
are saying okay you keep me saying all
this other stuff there were about i
would say there were about a thousand
people at the event it was a huge meet
and greet we opened it up to a lot more
people so i don't know maybe 150 or 200
people in that i met about 10 people who
work for disney so this meme out there
that everyone who works at disney is
some blue-haired hysterical leftist
lunatic i met he was probably 10 it
might have been even a dozen
employees of disney who said that a ton
of people hate what's going on there
they don't stand for any of this
nonsense or any of that stuff so that
was actually
quite refreshing anyway the whole talk
with desantis as i said will be up a
little bit later today you will hear
some good ideas
but we must juxtapose good ideas with
bad ideas and speaking of bad ideas
here's joe biden
since i took office families are
carrying less debt their average savings
are up a recent survey from the federal
reserve found that more americans feel
financially comfortable than any time
since the survey began in 2013.
do i even have to add anything to that
like that is some gen sake level lying
yeah are you feeling more financially
comfortable everyone knows a recession
is about to hit mark my words guys make
a note of this one mark my words a
recession is coming everyone knows it
it's probably coming in late june early
july mid july something like that but in
effect it's here the the price of
everything is up i've told you many
times i got a whole bunch of workers in
my house right now windows screws two by
fours plywood you all know this the
price of cars the shortage when it comes
to baby formula all of the stuff go buy
chicken breast at the store is it more
expensive or less expensive is your
dollar going further or less far is gas
up or down like every single thing that
he just said there is a lie now again i
get it
joe biden is an old confused man
pretending to be president he's not in
charge and he's just reading what
someone puts in front of him and he has
no uh he's simply not in touch with
reality and he is a shell of the
whatever that guy was you know the guy
that's been in government for 47 years
but it's just a perfect example of how
everything that they say is a lie we've
shifted into this weird thing where the
the regime and the regime media the
democratic establishment and and their
media cohorts and virtually everyone in
the democrat party all they can do is
lie they cannot do anything else because
they're so deep in the morass of their
own bs
and it's not just that they lie about
everything they exaggerate about
everything they confuse all of the
issues and everything else here's a new
york representative monday jones saying
the quiet part out loud about a little
something enough of your thoughts and
prayers enough
enough
you will not stop us from advancing the
protecting our kids act today
you will not stop us from passing it in
the house next week and you will not
stop us there
if the filibuster obstructs us
we will abolish it
if the supreme court objects we will
expand it and we will not rest until we
have taken weapons of war out of
circulation in our communities
okay so everyone that uh is in the
government
whether you're a congressman whether
you're a senator whether you're the
president et cetera you are sworn in to
protect the constitution of the united
states that's what you're sworn in to do
and if you do not do that you are in
dereliction of your duties and you
should be impeached or removed now i get
it that the machine doesn't really work
right it doesn't work right it doesn't
work like that but what that guy just
said
and this is just standard progressive
nonsense what is he doing he's very very
angry right he's very angry and he has
righteous indignation and i'm right
because i'm angry and i'm so angry that
obviously i'm right that's the the
double logic right that's the circular
logic that these guys use and they use
this with absolutely everything but you
will not stop us you people who do not
agree with us you will not stop us and
not only will you not stop us the the
machine itself the structure of the
united states the laws that we all must
abide by to be here uh the 250 year old
documents that were set up to free
people and have done it in an absolutely
extraordinary way we will destroy those
things if possible we will destroy
the supreme court and the separation of
powers and the three branches of
government by packing the court if
necessary so it can do legislatively
what we cannot do right now we will
destroy every piece of the thing if you
do not do what we want i don't know how
you could be in more dereliction of your
duties to do that of the oath of office
that you swore i assure you that donald
trump never threatened to break down a
branch of government but this is this is
mainstream stuff in the democrat party
there will be no democrat that will say
guys that's a bit of a bridge too far to
try to take out one of the branches of
government they're just gonna keep going
with it and keep going with it uh but
let's move on to uh video of uh jake
tapper over on
cnn because there's a lot of things
happening right now it's not just about
guns it's about the economy it's about
the whole thing take a look two things
sure stand out in this new poll one the
economy a top priority and two americans
disapprove of president biden's handling
of this more than ever before yeah and
those two things together uh spell a
tough political environment for
democrats the president and his party
take a look here most important issue
it's by far jake 50
of people in this poll say the economy
is the most important issue facing the
country russia ukraine ward 14
immigration at 10
everything else in single digits we
should note this poll was completed just
before that bombshell news from the
supreme court on abortion biden's
handling of that number one issue
only had a 34 approval rating on the
economy 66 disapprove and that number
there jake that's been going down since
our poll earlier this year he was at 37
approval on the economy now he's down to
34
and in terms of biden's policies look at
this a majority of americans in this
poll 50 55
say biden's policies have actually
worsened economic conditions 26 percent
no effect only 19
of americans in this poll say biden's
policies have improved conditions
okay so this is actually kind of good
right that is the corporate press
acknowledging what we can all see
that something is not right right now
right i should have shown you that one
right after the biden clip that we
showed you um a moment ago uh because
biden is saying one thing in terms of
the economy and how much money you have
and then the polls and then the reality
that we're all seeing are are very very
different so now i want to jump back i'm
going a little herky-jerky today but
just follow along uh here is another
democrat this is rhode island
representative david cicilline
and he doesn't like the constitution
either
so spammy the [ __ ] about
constitutional rights
no i will not yield and i'm not going to
yield for my entire five minutes so
don't ask again
you get it you get it he's very angry he
doesn't care about your constitutional
rights and
believe people when they tell you what
they are that's that's really i suppose
the theme today
there is no one left in the democrat
party that is a moderate i am not
talking about your aunt who thinks that
the democrat party is the democrat party
of 1996 bill clinton and i am not
talking about your grandma who thinks
that it's the democrat party of jfk
there is no one left
simply nobody left and no one will stop
this thing it is taking over the entire
thing and as i often say
you don't have to be a republican but
you cannot be a democrat however you
probably should be a republican at this
point and now again with our herky-jerky
motions today
they are they lie about everything they
lie about everything and they obfuscate
about everything here's gay pete and uh
gay pete uh he feels uh that biden's
doing uh pretty good americans feel gas
prices just about more than anything
else we're seeing five dollars a gallon
approaching five dollars a gallon across
the country right now as we head into
the summer vacation season
earlier this year the president tapped
the strategic petroleum reserves that
hasn't made any difference at all was
that a failure
look i i don't think it's correct to say
it hasn't made any difference at all
this is an action that helped to
stabilize global oil prices uh the
action the president took around ethanol
introducing additional flexibility there
that's having an effect on prices in the
midwest but we also know that the price
of gasoline is is not set by a dial in
the oval office
he's just nothing gay pete is just a
suit he's just a suit with talking point
that's all he is uh first off gas prices
have doubled
doubled since joe biden took office when
he kept calling this thing putin's price
hike we've covered this many times gas
was already up over a dollar a gallon
before in the year before the russian
invasion of ukraine so anytime anything
goes well they want credit for it but
when things go now well well
you know joe biden doesn't have a dial
he can't do anything but the craziness
from these people and i guess that
really is the theme of the show today is
is sort of like
after i spent you know 45 minutes with
the with probably the sanest guy in
america uh ron desantis and just like
honest clear policies just like
the collection of just like insanity all
over the place uh is just it's so it's
just so freaking obvious right now and
it's absolutely everywhere it's not just
our political leaders and it's not just
these i don't want to call these people
leaders it's not just these awful
politicians who want to destroy who want
to lie to you or destroy the
constitution and destroy the country and
it's not just the media that
occasionally gets some things right it's
also our corporations the corporations
have gone all in on this woke nonsense
as you know and uh now when i'm i grew
up on the island okay now on long island
there's a tradition of good pizza we
have good pizza the idea that you would
go to pizza hut let's say in long island
is crazy you would never go to a chain
right you go to marios you go to luigi's
basically someone who was in a nintendo
game that's the name of the pizza place
that you're going to go to that would be
the same thing if you're in jersey
something like that but pizza hut is a
pizza chain i get it it's throughout the
country and they're really into the drag
queens these days take a look at this
uh this is a tweet to commemorate pride
month pizza hut is recommending books to
children about drag queens this is from
the post-millennial
and you can see bigwig
by jonathan hillman who i don't know who
he is
that is one of the books that pizza hut
is now recommending because as you get
your crappy generic pizza with their
cheese filled crust which nobody does
anyone like the cheese filled crust it's
enough it's enough already right uh you
know you really want to also learn about
gender and sexuality and cross-dressing
and drag queens from your fast food
pizza place in
sanity but i've got more insanity we've
got another one from the post-millennial
here's what's going on over in cali
a proposed california bill to authorize
heroin injection sites passed its final
committee approval earlier this week and
heads to the state
assembly this is what is happening
across
blue states and blue cities all over the
place we showed you last week that that
billboard in new york city and the
subway where they're basically promoting
heroin they're basically saying hey if
you're on heroin don't feel guilty about
heroin just uh make sure you're doing it
okay do it safe right and here they're
gonna put more heroin sites in
california california the [ __ ] which
i fled los angeles the dump which this
guy fled and this lady fled uh daphne by
the way is in studio today michael and
uh michael and phoenix are they're both
a little under the weather i don't want
to freak people out it happens it
happens it's okay i'm not going to force
them to be injected with heroin or a
vaccine or anything else hope you guys
are doing well
but my entire team fled that craptastic
place because of the heroin that was
everywhere because of the needles that
were everywhere because of the homeless
that was everywhere because of the crime
that was everywhere and the shooting and
the garbage and all of that stuff but
they just want more and more and more
and more
and not only do they want more they're
also prepping their own audience to not
accept the results of the next election
i know they like to say that we are all
conspiracy theorists
right they had four years of trump where
they said he was illegitimate he was a
russian asset facebook somehow installed
him all of the nonsense that they pushed
for four years that's what they said
then the second trump dares question the
election or other people question the
election or janesh d'souza makes a
documentary about it etc
everyone else is a conspiracy theorist
we should be banned from twitter kicked
off facebook and everything else but
they are prepping their audience right
now
so this is video from msnbc which is a
televised mental institution this is a
woman by the name of tiffany cross don't
know who she is i guess she's a host
over there
and they know see the thing is they know
that right now because of the horrible
bite in numbers there is going to be a
crazy red wave but as i always say you
can't get too excited about that or you
can't be too overconfident because god
knows what they could do right before we
get coveted too we get monkey pox eight
they you know russia drops a nuke they
could just do anything right like so you
can't get too overconfident but they're
prepping their audience to not accept
the results of the election because they
really do fear that there's gonna be a
red wave and it'll be okay when they
question the results take a look
bombshell new reporting from political
detailing just how deep the republican
plot goes when it comes to trying to
subvert the midterms this november and
of course the general election in 2024.
now according to the recordings of
republican party operatives this was
obtained by politico their plan includes
a multi-pronged strategy this plan to
subvert the election should not come as
a surprise they've been telling us since
they lost in 2020 they know their
policies are trash they know they can't
win election on the merits so it sure
looks like at this point they're going
to cheat because they're telling us
they're going to cheat to make sure they
win instead
it's an absolute mental institution up
there but do you see what they're doing
they're prepping their people they're
prepping them to not accept the results
of the election in case they don't get
the results that they want they don't
they're she's saying their policies are
trash okay how are the policies of the
biden administration going when it comes
to say foreign policy when it comes to
economic policy when it comes to
literally anything
literally anything how are those things
going not well lady
but this is what they're doing so just i
show you that just to be aware of the
tricks right if we know their full bag
of tricks we'll be able to fight back
and speaking of fighting back this is
how we will put a nice bow on today's
show bringing it back to where we
started let's start with this ron
desantis guy again how do we fight back
will you call out the nonsense whenever
you see it ron desantis a couple days
ago what has he done since he came into
office he immediately
immediately waged war against american
energy production you see record gas
prices in the united states well that's
a big reason why because of his policies
you look at what they did in terms of
fiscal and monetary printing and
borrowing trillions and trillions of
dollars what did you get for that the
most sustained inflation this country
has seen
in over 40 years
he advocated for and imposed
mandates and restrictions related to
covet including having people fired from
their job based on getting a kovid jab
or not that has had a hugely negative
impact
on the economy and he failed to take
leadership and take decisive action to
alleviate the supply chain crisis that
we've seen
really beguiling not only this country
but places around the world
clear
clean honest calling it out for what it
is and instituting better better
policies that's what we're doing right
here in the free state of florida uh we
got one more desantis for you uh this is
one of the craziest things that that joe
biden or the man pretending to be joe
biden or the man that was joe biden has
been up to they want to deny school
lunches for states that refuse to
implement gender ideology yes
really they want to punish
states that will not play along with
their woke gender nonsense desantis
ain't having any of it we're prepared
for what biden throws our way uh and you
know yes part of it's the inflation and
the gas part of it are intentionally
destructive policies like trying to deny
school lunch programs for states that
don't do transgender ideology and the
schools i mean give me a break
totally off his rocker to be doing that
we're fighting on that don't worry so
we're just prepared to be able to defend
the taxpayers and the hard-working
people in the state of florida and i
couldn't be prouder for for doing that
and i couldn't be prouder to be a
citizen of the free state of florida
that's how you fight back
uh by the way guys it is meme monday
over at the reuben report locals
community here's what i put up
a full list of scenarios where giving up
your rights will make you safer and uh
zero there ain't jack on there you can
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and i just want
to say for all of you that i met in
orlando the locals community i'm talking
about specifically the hundred or so you
that came to breakfast it's like that's
what it's all about talking to a camera
is one thing tweeting at people is one
thing texting videos all that stuff
meeting all the people and so many of
you gave me candles and tequila a lot of
you gave me tequila but candles and
tequila and baby clothes and cookies and
chocolate what else did people give me
they gave me a hand painted amazing art
from people from their kids and just
like so much great stuff and i am like i
was going to say blanche devereaux but i
am blanche i'm like blanche dubois
i rely on the kindness of strangers but
you're not strangers to me so you guys
can play along at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with uh orlando magic star
jonathan isaac is up right now full
interview with dinesh d'souza is up
across platforms right now we'll see how
long youtube
lets us
keep that one up we shall see about that
uh and we're gonna cold close with the
same thing that we did on the cold open
there just the intro for ronda santa's
just so you can feel some of that energy
but as i said the full interview uh will
be up later today or some of the clips i
think are going up later today and the
full be out later this week yeah and uh
and then
my talk will be going up as a special
and i promise you you will laugh you
will cry it has a little bit of
everything uh anyway that's monday for
you uh get your week off to a good start
enjoy yourselves enjoy each other how
does i feel like i'm jerry springer you
know i remember jerry springer at the
end of the show be good to each other
okay all right get out of here
i moved to this great state six months
ago okay and i gotta tell you as i
opened with you guys have done it right
and it's it's you and it's you and it's
you and it's you and it's everyone in
this room and it's that florida man knew
something that the rest of us had
forgotten or maybe we never knew
and i promise you that i am here to keep
florida florida
and i'm also here to support this guy
ladies and gentlemen governor ron
desantis everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
the truth
yeah that's right
[Music]